hi I'm Maria Zuber I'm a postdoctoral
fellow in the Nagel lab at the
Neuroscience Institute at NYU Langone
health and the title of my talk today is
spencey in a dynamic world what the
antenna of the fruit fly can teach us
about sensation and perception of
movements so I'd like to start by saying
thank you to the organizers for the
opportunity to share this work with you
today and in the top I will present work
which is in part supported by a brain
initiative k99 for zero-zero award to
navigate through the world moving
animals rely on sensory cues to guide
motor circuits that drive behavior and
in neuroscience we often talk about from
sensory to motor but of course the frame
crucially has to coordinate between
sensory and motor systems continuously
so all of these animals rely on this
coordination and in humans there's
evidence that failures in these circuits
may result in abnormal behavior and
disease of the senses Makenna sensation
is perhaps one of the most mysterious
it's also very important for instance as
humans we've touched to manipulate and
explore objects the caring for young and
to protect yourself from injury it how
displacement at the periphery is
translated into a coherent percept is
not fully understood we also rarely
passively sense the world sensation is
often an active process where we move
and sense during the same behavior
how does our brain distinguish between
sensations we create with our own
actions from those originating in the
environment and what do animals actively
gain by actively moving their sensors in
this behavior
in my research I use the fruit fly
Drosophila melanogaster to tackle these
fundamental questions about neural
circuit function and behavior
the head of the fly which is showing the
image on the right houses many
specialized sensory systems for instance
their conspicuous red eyes mediate a
rapid visual system their two antennae
has numerous Humphrey systems including
a very sensitive sense of smell thermo
and hyper sensing systems and the
largest mechana sensory organ and animal
is in the antennae these sensory systems
are used to guide relatively complex
behaviors for example to locate distance
food sources during courtship and
aggression and during rapid flight
maneuvers and fruit flies perform all
these behaviors very well in laboratory
settings
so to give you a sense of the scale of
this organism in its brain here's the
body of the fruit fly which is about the
size of a sesame seeds
central explain which is distained in
blue here is about the size of a vanilla
bean speck on you know for example in
your ice cream to study these tiny
brains I use with many tools and in
particular I take advantage of huge
libraries of publicly available to
medical lines and there are thousands of
these lines which are inexpensive to use
and easily ship between labs with these
genetic lines I can target and
manipulate specific subsets of neurons
in the brain for example by expressing
light activated ion channels for opto
genetics or by expressing fluorescent
indicators like the green fluorescent
protein or GFP shown in this image in
green and using this I can target small
groups or single cells repeatedly across
individuals
using this person indicators as a guide
I can then measure the intracellular
responses from this genetically
identified neuron I report from single
cells using a highly precise technique
called wholesale patch clamp and in
these recordings I seal onto the cell
body of the neuron with a glass
electrode I break a hole in the cell
body through which I rapport the cells
tiny electrical current
this trace here shows the raw electrical
activity or membrane potential from
single central mechanic sensory neuron
and fruit fly and I presented the slide
with a sensory stimulus here and it
responds with changes in the graded
membrane potential as well as changes in
the frequency of these small amplitude
spikes overlaid on top these experiments
are hard but basically the gold standard
for recording neural activity by
carefully gluing in text flies to 3d
printed custom holders I can perform
these electrophysiological recordings an
intact and behaving flies
so here I'll show you a video of this
technique in action in the top right
will see an image of the fly from below
filmed by camera and I'll play the video
now and that trace the yellow trace on
the bottom shows the into the
intracellular activity or the neural
activity from a single sensory neuron in
the slide while it's fun so this
technique is incredibly powerful for
characterizing neural circuits during
the behaviors that they enable and
ultimately I aim to leverage these and
other tools in the fruit fly to discover
fundamental properties of neural circuit
function with the idea that these
studies may also shed light on
mechanisms in other organs
fruit flies have long been known to use
odors to locate food sources we now also
know that they use wind to measure the
direction from which these odors come
from
weenus transduce at the periphery and
flies by motions of the antennae so here
we show the head of the fruit fly again
and he is doing on one of the antennae
to look at fine structures in more
detail the antennae in fruit flies other
insect is segmented into the first
second and third segments and fruit
flies and on the fourth segment there is
a passive structure feather like
structure called the Arista and this
acts like a sail to mediate movements of
the third segment of the antenna along
the long axis in response to air
currents such as wind
so how our displacements of the antenna
translated into a perception of wind
directions
how this transformation occurs in the
brain was not clear so today my talk
I'll first tell you about how this
transformation occurs in the central
brain of the fly and then I'll describe
how these circuits function to encode
active movements
anyone directly I designed a stimulus
apparatus that enables me to deliver the
wind to the fly from five direction the
fly is mounted and holder in the center
of this apparatus indicated by the red
star on the Left image and I sell
movements of the antenna with camera
placed below this life
I'll show you a video of what this looks
like here we're looking at the fly's
head from below and this experiment I
presented a four-second tonic
winsomeness to the fly from negative 45
degrees relative to the midline I'll
start playing the video now but you may
want to keep your eye on the third
segment of the antenna and the Arista
when the green dot appears that
indicates when the winds Dinos is on
so to my eye and perhaps you were
movies are fairly subtle but I'll show
you later that there are neurons in the
brain that readily encode these
movements
with the help of school students in the
lab we quantified wind induced
deflections across many flies to obtain
an estimate of how these sensory
structures how the antennae themselves
encode wind direction so here I'm
plotting the average tuning of the left
antenna in magenta and the right in teal
in response to wind percentage from the
five directions and these deflections
are relative the midline of the fly and
as we would expect motions of the two
antennae are symmetric however we notice
something interesting when we focused in
on the tuning of a single antenna for
example the right antenna here and what
we noticed was that several wind
directions could elicit the same antenna
deflection which means that the wind
direction tuning of a single antenna is
ambiguous so for it if an animal was
hoping to pinpoint the source for
example of an odor it would have a
difficult time determining wind
direction using a single antenna however
if we compare the difference between
internal motions simply by subtracting
the left from the right disambiguating
disappears showing that the antenna
together could generate a linear
encoding of wind direction and this
linear encoding potentially one signal
that a fly uses to pinpoint a source of
odor or using other heaters so just this
comparison happens somewhere in the
brain i mentioned wind is transduced by
motions of the antenna and these motions
are detected by several hundred stress
receptor neurons located in the second
segment of the antenna which together
are called johnson's organ neurons or j
winds for short these neurons project
their axons to a region of the central
brain outlined in gray above called the
internal mechanical sensory and motor
Center or AM and C for short and work
from several groups have shown that
distinct subgroups of these neurons
respond to wind however how wind
information is encoded beyond this
primary processing center is not well
known
to understand how this information is
processed in the brain I first looked
towards two classes of projection
neurons called a MMC projection neurons
or APN for short which are anatomically
poised to receive wind direction
information because their inputs are in
the wind sensitive region of the MMC and
I hypothesized that these neurons could
encode wind induced deflections of the
antenna
I mentioned axillary responses from
single genetically identified APN
neurons and I targeted these neurons by
expressing gfp under control of specific
genetic lines and in this experiments I
performed wholesale patch clamp
recordings from animals mounted in the
same stimulus apparatus that I used to
quantify internal motions and again I
presented winds from five directions
the results from the EP tuner and here
in this slide the anatomy of an earnest
schematized in the top left image and
then a confocal stack is shown below in
the middle I've plotted the average
membrane potential across several flies
in response to a four second wind
stimulus and what I found was that these
APN two neurons are inhibited by wind
from all directions except wind on the
ipsilateral side for the same side of
the animal that I recorded this so on if
I plot the steady-state tuning of these
cells now on the right figure across the
five wind directions for single flies
and gray or crosswise in black I saw a
familiar hook shaped tuning so now if we
plot the average tuning of the APN
neurons on the left in in blue and
compare this to the tuning of a single
antenna on the right you see that
they're very similar and they share this
ambiguous in wind direction coatings so
the anatomy of these neurons is
restricted to one side of the brain and
so we might expect that the tuning of
this neuron is due to its unilateral
antenna inputs but we couldn't assume
this because there are neurons that are
contrary projecting at this level of the
brain so to test this I blocked input
from the ipsilateral antennas shown on
the left
plot and this shows that and in this
case this abolished Alwyn responses in
the fly when I blocked it from the
contralateral antenna there was no
significant impact on the wind tuning in
these cells so this tells us these APN
two neurons are receiving input
primarily from the ipsilateral antenna
farther neurons downstream in the brain
that might integrate information from
the two antennae to compute a linear
representation of wind direction to
identify such a circuit or cells in the
brain I was for higher order neurons
that might integrate information from
this region of the bread wedge where the
appian neurons projects you so I
performed in electrophysiological screen
to identify wind sensitive neurons that
receive inputs here and this was a
rather labor-intensive screen but
yielded an important discovery which was
a class of neurons that we called wedge
projection neurons or wpms for short and
the genetic line that we found that
labeled these two cells on each side of
the brain which each respond in same
manner appear to be part of a larger
class of the Kennison 3 neurons that run
along the same and a chemical pathway so
here on the Left figure I'm showing the
raw memory potential traces from this
cell in response to epsilon or wind in
purple during which this cell is excited
these cells are inhibited by wind coming
from the contralateral side shown in red
and in the middle when I plot the
average tuning across many flies we can
see that they should exhibit a beautiful
gradient of tuning to the intermediate
wind angle and plotting the steady state
responses on the right again it's for
single flies in grain across flies in
black we see that they have a quite
linear readout of wind direction and so
the ambiguity in wind direction coating
that was present at the level of single
antenna and if the second-order
projection neurons have now disappeared
Claes the tuning of these wpm neurons
and left in purple and compare that to
the antennal motion comparison we see
that each produces a quite linear
readout of wind direction so I guess
that the wedge projection neurons indeed
are integrating information from the two
antenna
the tested I compared response to the
flies with intact antennas are able to
detect wind with flies where I blocked
input from either the ipsilateral
antenna or the contralateral antenna
both of these manipulations result in a
reduction in wind direction tuning but
not a complete loss response further I
found that blocking inputs from both
antenna completely abolish the response
so this tells us that the neuron is
integrating direction information from
both sides and is receiving inputs
through the antenna these thieves
wpn which projection neurons combine
Direction informations from both antenna
a next aim to establish where in the
brain this happened this neuron directly
integrate the information and if so
where I pinpointed the likely location
of integration from the two antenna
using several experiments including dual
wholesale patch plant recordings precise
two-photon lesions of the
contralaterally projecting axons of
these cells optogenetic activation of
several commuted presynaptic cell types
as well as genetic silencing of these
same cell types so
these experiments I have come up with a
an updated circuit diagram for
understanding how wind direction
information is computed in the brain of
the fly and this is likely an
oversimplified diagram but gives us an
idea of how this likely occurs in the
brain so on one side of the brain and
tunnel movements are first detected by
primary mechanoreceptors in the antennae
this it's a lot of information is
integrated by the wpn neuron via AP into
AP and 3 NOS contralateral information
is likely provided by v1 neurons and
potentially other as of yet unidentified
cell types that were revealed in some
anatomical studies and the surrogate has
its mirror symmetric counterpart and
with these experiments I've worked out
who I believe is a sufficient circuit
for understanding how when direction
information is computed in the brain of
the fly and opens up avenues for
exploring how information is used in the
central brain next I wanted to know if
there's a behavioral correlate for this
if there's something important about the
use of both antennae in an important
behavior for the animal so one important
behaviour for fruit flies is finding
food and they do this using odors and
wind direction as I mentioned earlier so
for these experiments I turned towards
an apparatus in the lab if this is a
minute of miniature wind tunnels walking
wind tunnels which we affectionately
refer to in the lab at Manhattan wind
tunnels because I have a quite vertical
orientation and I'll play a video of
what these experiments look like we play
single walkie flies in these arenas and
we present a constant wind stimulus into
which we injected odor which is
indicated when the green light turns on
we can play this one more time and you
might notice that when the odor has
turned on the flies start walking and
running upwind this odor is an
attractive odor associated so there they
go running associated with food it's
apple cider vinegar in a previous
postdoc in the lab quantified this whole
Factory search behavior and what I
wanted to know was if there's something
important about the use of both antennae
in this very important behavior for the
animal so for these experiments that
collaborated with a graduate student in
the lab Andrew Matheson we placed a
single walking flies in the arena we
measured their behavior if you think
real-time tracking and a camera place
above the Flies and in the figure on the
Left I'm showing the trace of a single
flying one of these experiments the
black tracer of the 30 seconds before
the odor stimulus was turned on the red
trace shows at 10 seconds during the
other stimulus and the blue trace shows
the 30 seconds after the odor students
is turned off in flies with intact
antennae we quantify this upwind run
this red trace here as an increase in
the upwind velocity which is shown in
the central top plot when we block
inputs from both antennae by stabilizing
them the fly is no longer performance of
wind velocity run because they can't
tell from where this odor came from then
we noticed if you block inputs from one
time antennae either the left or the
right
licen performed an intermediate upwind
search and this experiment is an
agreement with previous results from
tethered flying lives and it tells us
that flies require both of their
antennae for robust upwind orienting
behaviors
so so far am i talking this first part I
showed that single antenna provides an
ambiguous information about wind
direction but a simple comparison across
the two antenna could provide a linear
evita and that integration of
information from the two antenna likely
curve at WP n inputs from a sum of a PN
and b1 inputs and then I showed that
robust wind based behavior requires
input from both behavior and overall I
describes in ascending sensory circuit
that translates and tunnel displaces
into a higher order wind direction
signal that the animals have been used
for wind based navigation
so now I will tell you about ongoing and
future work that I will leverage the
sensory circuits that I previously
characterized and describe in the first
part of my talk and now focus on
mechanisms of active senses
I think it's important to note early now
that fruit flies do actively move their
antennae so I'll show you a video here
of the fly don't from the front in this
in this video sheet this fly is attached
she's glitches at one of these holders
and she's in basically a windproof box
and I'm not presenting any sensory
stimulant to her she's not flying in
place so any movements you see of the
antenna here are self generated slice
produce antenna movements they can
control movements of their antennae
using tiny muscles at the base of their
antennas so what are the purpose of
these and other types of active
movements we observe in fruit flies
after something encompasses a very broad
range of behaviors including any where
the animal is actively moving its sensor
or emitting energy to alter the types of
sensory information it acquires there
many famous examples of active sensing
including psychotic eye movements of
primates electroreception and weakly
electric fish and whisking new roads
there are also many great examples of
insects performing active sensation and
behaviors for example during trail
following ants they will actively sample
odors on the substrate by tapping their
antenna to the ground stick insects and
cockroaches are great examples of
insects that use their antennae for
active mccanna sensory behaviors for
example cockroaches have been found to
determine characteristics about objects
in space based on their for instance
texture size and shape using internal
touch so they alter the frequency in
angle of their internal movements
against the object to do this studies in
these insects and the classic examples
on the last slide among others have led
to many important discoveries about
active sensing and yet we still don't
fully understand this phenomenon and
this is partly due to the complexity of
these circuits and accessibility of
these underlying circuit and so what I
want to know is how does the brain
accomplish these important behaviors
particularly at the cellular and circuit
level and so here I'm turning to Jos
table as a small circuit model for
active sensing to understand important
features of neural functions so I'll
show you a couple specific types of
active in town movements that fly's
perform and observes many different
types of internal movements I'm showing
you just a couple snapshots here so in
this video we'll see an example of a
unilateral antenna sweep
we were looking at the flag from below
here and you'll see her right antenna
sweep again
I also observe examples of coordinated
movements of the two antennae like here
I think this looks kind of like a shrug
or maybe even an eyebrow raised
and in the next video I'll show you an
example of several types of active
movements which are overlaid with
passive boomers in the antennae again
we're looking at the slide from the
front here halfway through this video
the fly starts flying
and you can probably tell when she
starts flying because her in tub are
brought into this more frontal position
so she's flying in place here she's
glued to be holder but her wings are
moving although we're focused on her
antenna here and you may also notice
this vibration of the wings but I'm
sorry of the antenna just blurring of
the antenna which is a passive vibration
induced by the movements of the wings
and then we also observe a small flick
booth like movements of the antennae
during flight you'll notice here a
couple of slick like boots so we see
active movements upon active movements
combined with different passive antenna
losses as well
frontal positioning reflex that we
observe here is observing all flying
insects however we don't fully
understand what the sensory consequences
and function of this positioning
reflects it is and I'll come back to
this a little bit later but how we
quantify these internal motions to do
this carefully and quantitatively we
need to precisely track the different
pieces of the antenna and for this hand
tracking is not feasible based on this
volume of data that we have so instead
I've turned to machine learning tools to
automatically track the position of
these different features in these videos
so I'm currently using deep lab cuts
which is a relatively user-friendly
open-source package proposed estimation
based on transfer learning and deep
neural networks and so to do this what i
what i do is i hands label a couple
dozen frames from these videos it takes
an afternoon or so and this training set
is sufficient to train a robust network
for tracking the different segments of
the antenna in these videos and the
results are often close if not better
than human accuracy so I'll show you
that video that is unilateral antenna
sweet video again but now with different
features in an antenna automatically
tracked using this machine learning tool
so what I can do now is track the
individual segments of the antenna for
example the third and second segments of
the right and left antenna and I can
quantify how these different segments
move relative to each other during
self-generative or active movements
versus externally induced or passive
modes in the antenna
I'm currently characterizing the neural
encoding of the self versus externally
generated a tunnel movement so far as
observed surprising differences in how
central Meccano sensory neurons encode
these different types of stimuli namely
that some cell types appear to encode
all movements of being tiny including
both the active and passive components
whereas others appear to only encode
externally induced motions or passive
motions and remain unchanged during
large active movements
so if some neurons in this wind circuit
respond only to externally generated
movements this implies that they must
subtract the effect of the self
generated motion
so this signal so perhaps a subtractive
predictive signal from the motor system
and this type of signal carrying
information about self-generated stimuli
is sometimes called an efference copy or
corollary discharge in here I will study
the cellular basis for this feedback
using this small circuit model in
drosophila to identify the source of the
feedback I'm starting by mapping the
motor circuits controlling internal
motions which up until now were unknown
inter sauceless so it started by mapping
motor neurons at the periphery and I'm
working my way up towards higher-order
motor circuits that control these motor
neurons controlling movements of the
antennae
so to track down these motor neurons and
gain access to them to test our
hypotheses about predictive motor
feedback and screening for genetic lines
that label motor neurons and I performed
two parallel screens which each will use
these huge databases of genetic lines
and I we select candidate genetic lines
using very nicely characterized known
motor neuron anatomy in larger insect
and we use those to select candidate
genetic lines and then in this first
screen what we've done is we've
expressed where are some indicators
under controls of specific lines and
then we carefully dissect off the
antennae and image them and these
experiments are in collaboration with an
undergraduate in the lab Ashley Medina
and through this process we found
several great motor neuron candidates
that innervate the first segment of the
antenna where the muscles are in a
complementary screen I'm using
optogenetics proach and here again I
have many candidate genetic lines and
these I expressed in the red shifted
light activated cation channel crimson
which is a channel reduction variant and
I activate these different circuits with
the assumption that if I've labeled or
I'm activating motor neurons or motor
circuits we'll observe some measurable
difference in a talent motion so again
I'm using machine learning to almost
automatically track the antenna in these
videos and indeed this screen has
yielded a several additional great motor
neuron candidates that when activated
induce stereotyped deflections of the
antenna and anatomy of the antenna
subsequent anatomy helps to confirm the
identity of this motor neurons this
screen also has the potential to
identify higher-order motor centers
which we can distinguish from motor
neuron candidates using anatomy and
restricted genetic tools this screen is
also identified a genetic line that
labels one of the muscles in the base of
the antenna which is shown here
so with the motor nerds identified I can
now go and directly measure the
contribution of these cells in sensory
encoding by different classes of sensory
neurons in this pathway so for example
do the motor neurons themselves carry a
signal that counteracts a self-generated
movement system speeds the whole based
on the particular anatomy of the circuit
and the size of those four helpful brain
and then we can go from here and
characterize higher-order motor centers
and test their potential the event went
to the sensory pathway as well
so using these new genetic tools to
target the underlying motor neurons and
muscles controlling movements of the
antennae I can directly now test
hypotheses about the sensory
consequences of active movements so you
may recall that flight positioning
reflex in which the flies move they're
intended to a more frontal positioning
during flight and what I can do now is
use optogenetic to activate either
muscles or motor neurons to artificially
induce motions of the antennae and then
test what the consequences are of this
flight positioning reflex in the
encoding of wind direction or velocity
by the antenna themselves and I can test
the sensory consequences of this
position reflect on the sensory
responses of different wind sensory
neurons
so that last experiment is a good
example of the flavor of experiments I
will use to understand why animals
perform active sensing and precisely how
did these news exchange the information
acquired by its sensory systems and for
what purpose using Drosophila I can
precisely connect neural activity and
behavior using these powerful genetic
tools to nail down these important
questions at the cellular circuit and
behavioral level today I described how I
elucidated in novel makino sensory
circuit that encodes wind direction by
integrating information from the two
antennae and then I describe several
subsequent research areas that will
enable me to detect the mechanisms and
complete circuits underlying active
sensing in this system
my goal for this work is to shed light
on fundamental computations that enable
active sensing
I would like to thank my postdoc advisor
Kathy naval nail and current and former
members of the lab in particular in two
individuals that directly contribute to
the work I showed you today and remaps
Encinitas our car Matthew Miata and
Ashley Medina several members of the
Neuroscience Institute my former
graduate advisor Michael Dickinson and
my funding sources including the Leon
levy Foundation and the brain initiative
which is currently funding Mistura
canyoneering r00 award through the NI
ends DF thank you